alright guys bangbang I am super excited
about this conversation because I was
just home Denise that she has a an
amazing job I'm frankly jealous of what
she gets to do every day so thanks for
taking the time to do this for sure for
those that don't know you and your work
maybe let's just start kind of what did
you do growing up and then also from an
education standpoint in order to start
down this path well so here's the funny
thing you know I do like mental and
decision coaching with psychoanalysis or
variations there but I started out
working for IBM and I really started out
in college I'm a nutrition and dietetics
biology major thinking of to do
something in healthcare then got swayed
by IBM and thought I was gonna climb the
corporate ladder and start doing great
you haven't big accounts of getting it
works and then I thought oh my gosh if I
wake up at 40 and I'm selling computers
like so I ditched an opportunity to go
to business school on accidents and
finagle my way and program at the
University of Chicago a master's program
we kind of design their own and that the
time is called bio psychology which is
like okay we had a psychology like
what's the biology like what is the
brain it's not called neuro
psychoanalysis but literally I swear
this is true like took a left turn in
downtown Chicago with a friend of mine
who had been a floor trader at the see
bona Options Exchange and like became a
trader with another planet later like
and before I do I spend like what's my
plan so it's a wacky story really and so
what exactly do you spend all day doing
right I think when people hear things
like psycho analyst and and all of kind
of the
all sexy terminology they say I know
that's important and I don't want to
talk to that person because they're
gonna analyze me but what are you doing
on a day-to-day basis for 20-some years
he's got lots of things going on he's
got like a private investment vehicle
he's got a guy that's had code is maybe
not recovering and so like we just went
through everything that's on this plate
and he's thinking out loud with me and
I'm helping him you know sort through
what he thinks and what he feels about
each situation so they can figure out
like what he really believes in what he
wants to do and this is a call that I
didn't really feel like I didn't listen
and provide a few sort of observations
but it's like because you don't get the
time to just sit back and talk to
someone about like everything that's
going on in your business and have that
person to understand and reflect and ask
some good questions at its core
I'm always looking for what is the
person feeling about what they're saying
the key was talking about having two
different possibilities for this special
purpose access vehicle like a company to
invest in and at first we described the
one company and they described the other
company I was like oh he definitely
wants to go for the first one and so I
reflected that back I think so it's a
lot of listening reflecting helping the
person really just understand themselves
better and he's always saying to me
Denise what's your psychoanalysis me
what do you really think of me well I
have yet to tell him because it won't
help him for me to tell you in those
situations right how much of it is when
they are
or just listening to you or you're
listening to them versus you're actually
giving them feedback like the value of
just sitting and thinking out loud and
talking through it and then all of a
sudden they're like oh I know what to do
because I just had to sit and think
about it versus you're sitting there and
say yeah you're thinking about this
wrong or you're being incredibly biased
and actually almost acting it's like
guardrails mentally how do you balance
the value between those two things that
you provide yeah I say I'm never give
advice
now that's less true than it used to be
it's been particularly less true during
this crazy market period but I think of
it in terms of I create my own analysis
of what that person's going to what's
really happening for their like where
they're conflicted what they're
confident they probably can't see for
themselves because it's just too hard
seekers heart and then I try to ask
questions such that it don't figure out
what I see but what tends to happen is I
do you know people do end up trusting me
and because I have some market
background and they want to know what I
think
sometimes early on the client will say
well how would it be helpful to know
what I think I think my skill it's
really helping to know what they think
like really what they think and getting
out of their heads you know in in
understanding what their intuition is
what they're experiencing pattern
recognition is you know there or like it
or where they're conflicted like the
kind of guy and then applying it well
this is the one that I get one
psychoanalyze I don't tell me what my
psychoanalysis of them is psychoanalysis
he wants to be a leader like that was
really why he hired me to be more of a
leader in his small organization
but yeah like he's really afraid of
stepping out of taking a risk or a
creative disagree too much or even if we
really kind of afraid of being seen
sorry I'm like okay let's make a list of
things you want in what it takes it
let's make a list of the fears you have
I didn't I could see that they were in
conflict right and I bet you can see
they're in conflict as I explained it to
you but it wasn't so he wrote them down
on paper he's like wow I can't have this
if I've got that I didn't tell him that
I I often give you know Oh pieces of
homework you make a list of write down
this versus that to help people come to
realizations yeah it makes a ton of
sense and I guess you've done this for a
long time and you've come up with your
own method as to kind of how to how to
think through some of this stuff so
maybe help us understand how the method
works and then we can get into more of
just like how the brain works how
processes risk and all that but what
exactly is this method bill well it
assumes that how someone feels is the
most important thing and if there's
always a good reason for why the person
feels the way they do like in their
circumstances in their situation so it
has like ultimate respect and it gives
ultimate respect for whatever the
person's experience of their world is
that's different you know that's
different than a lot of methods that
might have like a cognitive bias you
know you're making a stinking mistake
we're not like that
we've sort of assumed that yo you have
you have some conflicts between things
that are going to you on different
timeframes but basically everything
makes sense it's a matter of helping you
sort it out I think of it and it's
helping figure out what emotions they're
conscious of like what they know about
themselves and what they don't know
about themselves
like the conscious emotional
constellation and the unconscious
emotional constellation and where the
unconscious one is getting in the way of
whatever they want consciously but it's
very you know it's very empathetic it's
very respectful it's very it makes soap
like we know it makes sense it's just
figuring out what's unconscious in
what's in conflict and then leading them
to it and in the process than what you
find is some people want to know
everything like tell me tell me tell me
one about a lot of people like one of
them but then they have a whole list of
reasons why no that's not right and
that's not going to help me
so we categorize that as resistance in
the same way a psychoanalyst would but
it's not a bad way we try to work with
it so that the person changes on their
person comes to realize it on their own
yeah I guess part of this is you have
the pleasure of talking to what I'll
call the full stack right everyone from
somebody who is a young person who wants
to become a leader in an organization to
somebody who is kind of we'll call it
middle management or middle of their
career and maybe happy where they are
and just want to get some better
performance or may not be happy and kind
of want to accelerate but then you also
talk to the absolute best in the world
as well and so as you've been doing this
what are some of the things that you've
noticed the best investors traders what
do they do that separates them from
everybody else is it simple things or
they flex some nuance like that the top
1% what separates them mentally from
everybody else well if it's market
investing in Cheney they understand that
the market is just a social game that
there's no like absolute then it's
really just
section like in its waves of the ocean
of perception changing and so they're
they're training against other people's
perception and whatever you know
however they analyze it whether they use
technical analysis and charts or
fundamentals and you know value that's
just like a clue to how people's
perception is changed so they just
understand the market as human beings
like waves in the membership and it's a
really different way to like to have
internalized market plus they use their
feelings I mean they really do use their
feelings like they know that conviction
is an emotion and they can tell the
difference between when they're
convicted in something for the right
reasons or when they're like agitated
and compelled to do something but it's
for the wrong reasons like you know
another investment didn't go well the
IRS showed up or like in my mind they're
using their they're using their brain
the way the human brain is really
designed which is school something I
think neuroscience is really just
starting to reveal to us and kind of the
assumptions we've had about it centuries
it's all wrong but they like intuitively
come to that like they through their
experience they they get the model of
what's happening right and they get like
a mechanism of how thinking about it
works best right and do you feel like
that that almost it sounds like it
reduces the pressure of some of the
decision making right if there are no
absolutes if you're simply playing this
social game and the market is a signal
of how everyone within that market feels
it feels like that's a little bit less
of a pressure situation then if I said
to you you're gonna be right or wrong on
a daily basis is that direct fact it's
not like you have to find a secret
answer that's lurking out there you know
the class
your you have less of a feeling that
you're searching for the Holy Grail and
more of a feeling that you're circling
and so it's like keep my balance you
know and in private the ways and that is
easier it is easier yeah and would it be
fair to say the other thing that you
said that I think I understand is that
the best in the world are focused more
on the decision-making process rather
than the actual decisions themselves I
think that's true I'm not sure I said it
but I think that is true that people
have a given that a strategy that they
do it once here they want to look at it
this way this way this way in Texas Fox
checks this box checked this box now
they also understand that they're
predicting an unknowable future because
that's what it is right none of us know
what's gonna happen half an hour let
alone them tomorrow works and by the way
the brain works on a prediction
prediction mechanism so again they're
like in concert as opposed to creating
friction but we always say that like
knowing the way that you interact with
the market like whatever your strategy
is and sticking with it is definitely
the better way to go right so that's a
process yeah explain that more right so
like what it is that a discipline thing
when you say kind of understanding
almost like your circle of competency
and and just sticking to that well it's
like knowing through what lens does the
market makes sense to you like often I
got Twitter all but I'll tell people you
got your philosophy of the market is and
what your philosophy of stops are like
what's she talking about
maybe yeah first of all we do everything
based on past experience in like the
scaffolding of beliefs so it helps to
know what you believe because like all
the information your your turn
through your police so I'm saying what
make sure you know what you believe
there are a million different ways to
make money in your market you just have
to figure out like what yours is just
like you know there's a million
different ways to play football baseball
basketball right like we'll have there
there's Pacific combination was the same
so you got to figure out what that is
like how does the market make sense to
you like what's your analogy for it like
to surfing do it because it's not a
sport like but it's not a sport like
football or baseball and then how you
stick with it and how do you understand
when you're confident in what you're
seeing and when you're not how do you
learn to make choices when you're
reasonably confident but not too hot not
which is a process of knowing like your
own you know feeling it's like knowing
yourself yeah you've mentioned kind of
confidence or conviction a few times and
one of the things that's always
fascinated me is those two lines are
very blurred and also somebody can be
convicted when everyone else isn't and
if it goes well they look back and they
say wow that conviction was a an
incredible ally to sticking with
something and ends up working but
obviously if you are convicted in
something it ends up being wrong then
people look back and say no you were
just almost religious about that whether
it was investment or trade or whatever
and it ended up leading to your demise
how how does that break down mentally in
terms of it's the same conviction right
but but it's almost driven somewhat in
hindsight by what the outcome ends up
being how do you think through that is
like think of every single word they can
possibly think of that relates to
conviction or is like a degree
conviction and then
rank those come up with some sort of
ranking and usually do 1 to 7 from like
the least convicted which people will
use panicked or terrified on your the
opposite but too overconfident you know
oh the way to Rick to the Carell like
you're referring to and always know
where you are on your scale if you're
gonna move you know you're going to move
from let's say a 6 2 & 3 but you want to
be able to have a word for a degree a'
or an' intensity up and you want to be
able to have a word so the number 1 your
your ranking and treat yourself and your
getting to know literally your own
physical experience of being convicted
but then when it gets like you're so
sure this can't go wrong that's like red
flag you know that's like when your so
you know when you start to cross that
line
I found over the years of doing this
that the best trades come out of this
call feeling that you're right like
either sure I'm just right I just know
it's right and at the same time you like
I must be missing something because it
can't be this easy and being able to
have both of those feelings at the same
time where the confident one isn't
energized is it like doo doo doo doo doo
it's just like I just know there's no
but I must be missing something because
it feels too easy to happen they know
this time and time and time and time
again plants tell me their best traits
come out of that combination of feelings
so we try to figure out where that isn't
like a scale of 1 to 7 it's very
interesting that it almost sounds like
the preparation of having a system
writer or the scale as you said and
always being almost able to gut check
write and measure it really sounds like
a where and it like the self-awareness
aspect of this is super super important
because it is able to identify the bias
that some of them may have in their
decision-making process
yes the subway this is everything so I
think of it in terms of leading people
to that and then giving them tools you
know to develop it with mechanisms to
develop it and track it
yeah biased to me is a slightly
different thing because I think the more
truly self-aware you are the less you're
subject to the typical cognitive biases
you know that makes sense and then how
do you in times of uncertainty like we
have right now right earlier you talked
about unknowns in the future being the
biggest unknown but right now it's less
about the future unknown I think there's
just a lot of uncertainty which seems
tangentially related but but but almost
worse how do you talk to people about
processing information making sure if
they have the sound decision-making and
then really operating in a time where
every decision every action feels like
it just has more weight on it and
there's a lot of uncertainty in the air
so the first skill is just to be able to
sit with it is literally just to be able
to tolerate the uncertainty and go you
know what I can't meet what I think is a
good prediction or a good bet that's a
skill and a lot of people can't do that
and I think we're seeing like a lot of
decisions being made that are about us
waging the fact that that's an
uncomfortable place to be because when
you make a decision it feels a little
bit more certain just because you decide
it even though you know the California
schools are my example of that way a
week or so ago they said you know no
classes in the fall I'm like I'm a
whatever one has to keep they didn't
need to make that decision but it made
them feel like more certain so there's a
skill of just being tolerated then
there's like making lists okay what what
do we know what's not inevitable
what can we maybe find out a little bit
more about
and when did we really have to make this
decision like either someone you know
startup company New York thinks that
they heard me talk about like do I
really have to make the decision for
what period of time their their lease is
coming up I don't know I think it's in
the fall and the staff is all been like
are we going back arguing sign of weeks
the CEO has been like I don't know not
making that decision today we don't have
to make that decision today but again
how do you do that you just you have to
be able to tolerate the fact that you
don't know so there tends to be a bias
for action then I think that bias for
action is somewhat misguided now there's
this idea that people default to
inaction I think it's generally the
other way around you don't want to do
something to make the feelings go away
just live with the feelings you'll
figure out a better thing to do as time
unfolds I've always thought of it and
whether it's right or not as people want
to feel in control right and the way
they feel in control is that you do
something I can impact the situation
whether it ends up being good impact or
not and one of my favorite studies I
came era it was Vanguard or fidelity you
know somebody did a analysis on the
best-performing
accounts they had and in the retail
sector it was people who had forgotten
their passwords or died yeah look he's
probably wasn't a bad strategy
I guess the aspect of kind of
uncertainty and especially right now I
think is a time where people are
thinking about this is fear right so
uncertainty to me feels like I gave you
plot a scale it's not on the E
the end but it's not on the most extreme
of the hard decision making it's just
uncomfortable aspect you know fear is
like the extreme end of I am literally
scared I'm going to lose money make a
bad decision you know whatever it ends
up being how do you talk to especially
large asset managers right where that
fear if it ends up becoming reality they
don't just lose 20 bucks right we're
talking you know millions or tens of
millions of dollars other people's money
how do you talk to them about fear and
kind of walk them through when they are
fearful yeah so a superpower question to
be able to answer is what am I feeling
and why am I feeling so I try to get
them to put that fear into words and I
often try to try to get them to really
get to why it is so either I've asked
for more in the past two months then I
asked one time what's the worst that can
happen so again this is something I
think is a little bit different about
our method like we're going right at the
fear and almost universally the worst
that can happen actually if the person
really tries to answer that question
he's some version of catastrophe you
know they go through losing money losing
investors losing employees losing their
fun losing their spouse their life is
disaster over this is a long time ago
but I once had someone tell me and my
kids are drug dealers and prostitutes
like it's sort of a natural human
tendency to down deeper there you had
this catastrophe scenario and you don't
realize it because you're not going down
the rabbit hole because you're told not
to drive away but it's that catastrophe
prediction that's linked to spirits
that's influencing here
and what happens is when you look at it
go away well that's probably not likely
to happen but even if it is going to
happen there's like a hundred steps
between here and there that I can you
know over
that reality so I that's a long-winded
way of saying I get all the fears out in
the open and then we look at them which
ones are real and which ones are
exaggerated which ones are relevant to
whatever decisions you got to make right
now in which ones are irrelevant you
know meaning they're about something
else or they can be put off or so it's
like sorting through the spaghetti bowl
of fear when it's using this research
that sense emotion differentiation from
emotion granularity meaning like fear
panic nervousness nervousness worry
doubt like all the different intensities
being able to sort through that should
you act on it less ironic being able to
sort through it gives you a wider range
of choices and stop you from impulsively
acting on it just to feel better or to
feel in control yeah it's really
interesting again it's around awareness
right kind of having an understanding of
what's happening makes it less powerful
to some degree like the forces being
acted on you the the age-old question I
know somebody listening to this will ask
it is are the absolute best in the world
ever scared or are emotional control to
to avoid fear and maybe just sit with
the uncertainty or does it ever get to
that point maybe there's somebody out
there that's you know less even than the
next one but it's actually it's a
strength to be able to admit fear like
and also in its pure form it's a source
of information so I think the very best
in the world understand it that way that
you know some fears are are warning you
of something you should be afraid of
some are irrelevant the skill is to know
the difference so what are you scared of
when you go to work everyday I can tell
you what I realized I was scared of
using my own methods in the past two
months because I'm really gonna do it I
mean I do this - that's what am i
feeling and why am I feeling it
because I don't learn it doesn't matter
how bad it is if you get to the real why
the energy and intensity that feels like
loops like the distraction of it I think
it's because your unconscious is trying
to use the feeling to lead you just some
useful piece of information so it makes
you uncomfortable and then when you get
the piece of equation because okay dr.
attention we're gonna sleep so like I
don't know mid - you know late March
when the hospital situation in New York
City was you know really or exact there
were a few days there were I didn't
sleep that well and I could tell it was
agitated and obviously like I knew you
know like there's ambulances and like
this is a horrible situation and people
are dying but still I could like and
then I realize I was brushing my teeth
I'm like what am I feeling like and I'm
like and I realized that I had this lady
but it's me or my husband for something
else that would be bad at that point in
time right and literally that I was like
oh okay
that's what I'm afraid of well that's
right now there's no longer afraid I
slept like a rock that night so it was
just recognizing that I and I was
perfectly reasonable here I mean I have
another crazy situation that I did it
with when Cavanaugh was being confirmed
but probably not being Republicans
but same thing I was really agitated by
it and got right down to the real reason
that it was I mean obviously was gonna
be agitating to me as a woman in you
know but like why is this distracting me
in like preventing me from working and
focusing and then I play drill down and
what it really was yeah there's almost
not good but I was no longer
it wasn't disruptive but feeling losses
disrupt yeah and so I guess like when
somebody goes through that process right
how do you then take okay I've
identified what the fear is so you know
use the example of I might have to go to
the emergency room do you then take that
and put action into place or is it
almost like this mental piece that comes
with okay I now have identified what is
driving the fear maybe the fear doesn't
necessarily go away but like you said
the intensity is mitigated to some
degree because there's the awareness of
it and then the agitation goes away like
in that situation there wasn't really
much I could do I mean like I just I
mean I'll be personal I have like a
condition in my esophagus that it's
narrow at the bottom so sometimes if
they going to chew really really well if
you get stuck and I think an emergency
room twice in my life so like my things
are capable make sure you chew oh so
sometimes you get to that lie and then
you see what the real thing is and then
you go oh this is what I need to do
about that thing in it by the way it's
that's like way productive because
you're answering the frank question
you're not off trying to get rid of the
feeling because you think it's one thing
and it's another but sometimes just
knowing I mean like I have one portfolio
manager that you know keeps the zillion
positions on and trains a lot and I go
to his office and we go for a walk in
New York and look at we start walking I
have
new currencies and gold and you know I
was worried about my last question the
next thing I know he's on his phone
doing cell such-and-such and literally
as he said to me whatever he was worried
about her conflicted it had come to him
what did she do but it was the saying it
out loud to me and the understanding
it's important the listener actually
understands that caused him to know what
Louie should think as portfolio so in
other words it could be either he could
give you an action you need to do the
action would be better over long because
it's going to be more accurate based on
something more accurate but sometimes
just the awareness is enough to to calm
you down and then you know I don't need
to do anything about that yeah it's
super interesting is that normally how
you interact with clients like you go
physically in person and whether it's in
the office or go for a walk
is there kind of a method behind that
madness because it's kind of like a nice
office we you're not looking at each
other and so like I can have my eyes
closed and I'm really listening to the
tone of voice and I'm really listening
to the pauses and like I'm really
listening to how much agitation or
hesitancy is there and if the clients
not looking me or not looking at their
screen you know probably they're really
listening to themselves right so that's
like the third method so that's been a
good thing for me about the lockdown
I've been able to but I have certain
fine to just they don't feel comfortable
if they can't see me so yeah I go into
their office in New York and mode
there's only one that's really ever
insisted we take a walk on the regular
basis I actually left shoes in their
office because I'm like walking shoes or
different you make sure that they're not
looking at their screens while they're
talking to you well I can't if it's on
the phone you know I mean I can usually
tell by their cadence you know
I mean I I was born a really good
listener but I'm an even better listener
now because I've been training to do it
and I practice doing it and it just
generally speaking I mean you probably
know this during the podcasting we're
doing I mean it's a it's an art to
really listen and it's a real gift to
give somebody so really really listen
what are the kids what are the keys to
good listening no judgment no just
hearing what they're saying in a perfect
world and we use this and this might
sound contradictory to no judgment but
like the feeling it gives us there's a
phenomenon where someone's not in touch
with the feeling but someone like like
me or my team is listening you'll pick
up on the feeling so I got certain
clients over the years I had one
literally in the first 30 seconds I'd be
angry irritated anyone that in the first
30 seconds my dog would start barking
late yeah I say the dog over here the
person's tongue you know voice tone of
voice and energy you know I can't even
think that I've you and II wouldn't hear
it
so no judgement seeing what feelings it
gives you that's what we call it hearing
what's not being said hearing the
conflict like I'll say I think this and
they'll go on as if it's it's from here
but if you're listening you realize they
just said two things they're in conflict
and they don't realize yeah it's the
short version came really close
attention in and I've always thought
about you on the podcast for example
when you're talking with somebody the
more you focus on not just what they're
saying
how they're saying it you opening up a
whole new world and it sounds like that
for you is like on steroids right it's
every actor the pauses the cadence the
tone you know the inflection points all
of those things you're able to glean a
lot of information it is what it sounds
like yeah I could hear when someone's
not telling you something like when
they're thinking something but not
telling me and then I'll think it's like
I know this say everything getting
someone to say everything with no
embarrassment shame on their part helps
them but they need help to do it
oftentimes they will judge themselves
they'll think there's things they
shouldn't say so I listen for that what
are they not saying what about in those
moments of panic fear uncertainty any
like late-night calls we're just people
are freaking out I mean I tell my
clients you can email me or text me
anytime day or night and I'll answer you
in a reasonable period of time you just
don't do that if you I the group of
people that do it more are the athletes
but even then they don't well I'm gonna
say that cuz as soon as I said it'll
happen
what's the big difference between the
athletes and the investment
professionals I mean I think the big
difference is not so much between the
people is that is the situation so
investing or trading is just wildly
different than sports you know first of
all but the point is forces to make
something happen like you physically
make something happen the point of
investing or trading is to set yourself
up for something to happen it's a
completely different
environment you you know the game ends
you either won or lost like it's clear
you know the ball goes backwards it's
not good in investing the game never
ends the ball goes backwards I don't
know is that should you get out or is an
opportunity like the level of ambiguity
in investing is you know orders of
magnitude greater than it is in sports
which makes investing a lot lot lot
harder than sports but as far as the
people themselves you know athletes have
playing a team sport think of the world
in terms of the people like just like
the best investors to the athletes that
that are in individual sports like the
New York Times did an article about
Lindsey Jacobellis and me she's
snowboard racer you know that's me well
she's racing against four other people
and she just actually think a lot about
other people and hashes maybe anything
like a picture I've been working with
you know that's thinking about other
people you know I think I'm in some ways
I'm like everyone's human and everyone's
brain works like human being and I'm at
risk of sounding whatever they're all
the same to me but but I do think very
much what situation it they're like
three years ago I had a general manager
of a major league baseball team called
me and I watched more baseball the
following two weeks I watched and the
proceeding like fifty years of my lives
because I want to know what does it feel
like to be standing at second base you
know what I always think like all I mean
I didn't - sometimes what does it feel
like to you you know what is it that's
what I want to know because I want to
help them sort through that so they're
able to operate out of the feelings that
are helping them and giving them
information and able to avoid the ones
that aren't
yeah it's pretty crazy before we go to
wrap this up I want to talk about
routines right I played sports growing
up obviously
you listen to people whether they are
the best in the world
running a business investing or just
doing some hobby everyone always thinks
about their routine but it's usually
here's what time I wake up here's when I
eat you know and it's a lot of physical
action is their mental routines that
either you help people structure or
patterns you've seen in high achievers
or high performers in terms of how they
think about like that mental routine
they go through you know people do
things like meditating in imagery but
they use it you know there's not a
consensus as to how people use it I mean
I try to get them in the habit of what
am I feeling in my my feeling it all the
time and then picking the action that
gets them the thing that they want but
making sure they get re-centered in what
they want frequently you know whether
that's every day or multiple times a day
which is the thing you want more in the
long term is offering conflict with them
you want less in the short term until
like instead of telling the routine I
want is instead of telling yourself to
do the right thing be leading into the
thing you want more and saying what have
I got to do to get thing leveraging
desire like a routine of leveraging
desire but I'm also very non-judgmental
you know some people have a very like
step by step I'm going to do this every
day you know and other people just don't
operate like that you know and I'm
totally about let's figure out what
works for you but in your situation and
don't feel guilty that someone else does
XYZ yeah that makes sense there's a lot
of people who
who wished that they could hire you and
spend time with you and kind of benefit
from all the great work you do but they
just can't whether it's a you know for
whatever reason is what's your advice to
them as kind of the like watered down
version of the work you're able to do
where they can just get started at least
being more aware or starting to
implement some of the things that you do
in your practice and their everyday
lives stop judging yourself like just
like there's a reason you sink and feel
the way you do and you think and do the
things you do so stop judging try to
understand figure out why it is you know
some of it's gonna be like if you
perceive it as self-destructing it's
good but there was a reason that
developed over your life for some reason
to keep you safe just figure out what it
is and then figure out what you want and
work with it so what this means is don't
judge how you feel just know how you
feel
put it into words because the more you
do that the less it's gonna get in your
way and you don't have to tie yourself
do this doo doo doo doo don't do that
like makes me crazy like the discipline
of us have to say this like in the brain
research that like our frontal cortex is
controlling us and keeping us discipline
we're finding that that's not the way it
works we're choosing what we want we're
choosing how we want to feel so let's
times people choose a short term feeling
to take away an uncomfortable feeling
but to get the long term feeling you
have to do something different like they
have to go work out today or whatever
you know or you have to stay in a trade
no wait what are you feeling in my learn
how to answer that question and just
don't criticize yourself
I love how how simple of just like what
am I feeling and why right it's
something that's memorable and you can
do literally without
moving you could do it in your head and
in the moment and that makes sense what
uh what's the most important book that
you've ever read I don't even know what
it's called its top the red book in
modern psychoanalysis
it's crazy book like this going to be
the case of you have had I think it's
it's called the red book
well it's point is the red book but
literally it's like the actual title is
something like modern psychoanalysis and
the schizophrenic patient or something
because this matters there's a group of
psychoanalyst they're called moderns
they're different than Freudians they
don't worry about like interpreting
you're doing this because XYZ happen to
a child but what they figured out is
anger you don't know you have is a huge
thing so back to not judging yourself
like being able to know what you're
angry about with no judgments can turn
into a superpower and it can actually
eliminate like self-destructive
behaviors but it's so hard to do because
we live in a culture where like anger is
terrible and no one's supposed to be
angry and lp8 or you know and get some
criticize for the modern psychoanalyst
get amazing results with with really
severe mental issues see understanding
how to work with anger and we've gotten
like some amazing results through
helping people understand they're
hanging about something that when you
think about it darn good reason to be
angry about so let's stop judging it
let's understand sometimes it's all in
the past there's nothing can be done
about it but just giving yourself the
respect of accepting that like creates
energy and it creates optimism so that's
like you know level 3 or
for an agent talk about it in public
because people can't take it but so it
almost feels like if people read that
book they will get a different
perspective on a lot of this work is
that fair yeah me to read like it's it's
written by a psychoanalyst in the 1940s
or 50s there's a hunter there's irony
and calling it modern if it was written
in the 40s or 50s right yeah you know
after the guy that started this was like
kicked out of New York psychoanalytic
which is a big deal and like it was
probably because he said you didn't have
to be a medical doctor to be a
psychoanalyst and they were all like oh
yes you have to be a medical doctor he's
like no and he actually took patients
he'd cured of schizophrenia this is true
story your listeners gonna think I'm
crazy but well and taught them to be
psychoanalyst and he believed that you
could do that but I kind of think of one
that oh here's a great one the body
keeps the score by I'm gonna get his
name on Van der Kirk or van der pol the
body keeps his score it's a current book
and it's basically about how like things
happen to us over our life and we're
unable to deal with the emotions and
they get subverted into our bodies which
then makes me think of another one the
drama of the gifted child what is that
it's basically about how like little
kids you know if you're a smart little
kid you kind of figure out what your
family dynamic is early on and kids try
to save their families you know one
thing kicks dude by the way it's like if
there's you know whatever whatever
whatever is going on in their household
it's not good kids are narcissistic
right so they think everything revolves
around them so they blame themselves
you know if I just behaved that better
you know mommy and daddy wouldn't be
fighting when you're a kid that helps
you because it gives you the sense of
power and control in the situation for
you and that helps you but you're so you
need to lose that is you know what
happens if some people don't lose it so
they always blame themselves and then
you know you can imagine how that gets
in people's way in adult life the drama
the gifted child teach you through that
like how that happens and I've given
that to a lot of clients they're like oh
my god I love it I love it the this
listen this is why I ask the question
right is because I think there's a lot
of books out there that are out of the
mainstream kind of what's popular and
investing or business or technology
whatever but they're great books right
and so it's always fascinating to hear
what people choose I ask every single
person one last question and then you
get it asked me a question to end it the
question is about aliens are you a
believer or a non-believer okay what is
the logic you use to get to yes I agree
but what is the logic behind yes we can
see but the short version is after
shortly after my father died I went on a
cruise to hear this guy talk about past
life regression which I would have never
gone to accept him as a Yale trained
psychiatrist and my friend who was a
mergers and acquisitions attorney in
Kazakhstan oil and gas female so she's
serious woman said you gotta hear this
guy so I gotta hear this guy and he's
got a speaker with him who does like I
guess you'd call it Chandler I don't
know what the word for Diaz but talk to
the spirit world and I'm even it's been
how many years but I'm like
my father spoke to me no uncertain terms
to that guy it was yeah but things he
knew like there's no other way it could
be anything but so there's a lot we
don't know
so therefore I got a cheese yes I love
that I've never I've never had anyone
used that that perspective to us yes
almost
yes so why do you believe my whole thing
is someone obviously the galaxies on
galaxies on galaxies that are out there
you know it's just this vast vast world
but I actually think there's two
components and I have and I'll call up
the bias of I have the benefit of you
are the three hundredth person I've
asked this question to so I've heard a
lot of the the various theories here but
one is the definition of alien is very
broad and so if you just look at
something like the things in the ocean
there's probably things there that you I
and every scientist in the world has no
clue about right it's just so big and so
does that fall under a kind of alien
life right it's some people would put
yes if you would say no but on top of
that the other thing is when you start
to get into things around simulation
theories or our ability to actually see
right you know and there's an example
Dave column from Cornell was I was
talking about recently I think was him
where it's like look if you're an ant on
a highway
you only know like I'm trying to get
across this highway right there's like
this big thing that comes whatever but
like you don't have the intelligence to
understand kind of the vast world
outside of you know your little kingdom
of the highway right right and so if you
think about it from that perspective
like what are the odds that we as humans
were the ants and some other thing it's
not necessarily high in my opinion but
it's not zero right and so when you
start to kind of do math on all the
different variations of the theory like
that so yeah there's probability would
tell you that there's some other
intelligent life out there I also come
at it from let's make sure let's hope
were the superior intelligence right I
don't know if we want to be the inferior
one but I think that's gonna be more
luck if anything I really did just see
an article and it I can't I'm not gonna
be able to remember her in it or but it
was an incredible publication about like
the FBI's awareness of UFO you know and
I mean I'd like I'm not the kind of
person who's gonna go down that rabbit
hole right but I saw this and it was
like a serious publication and the
serious article man like huh so these
the reason why I probably and I'm
obviously guessing here but back in 2004
2015 there was a a cortical leak from of
these UFO videos and this was on you
know Reddit and Twitter and kind of went
went very viral in the conspiracy theory
world but just recently literally during
the kovat crisis the thing was the
Defense Department or whoever it is in
the government agency side they actually
released the videos and confirmed their
authenticity yeah and and so it's
interesting because they basically say
look we don't know what this is
they don't merely go as far as kind of
the conspiracy theory world of like hey
this is aliens or you know any of that
type of stuff but it's just this video
was taken we do not know what the yeah
and also the part to me that that guy
would kind of wave my hand at all of
this except for very small people people
way smarter than me say look we don't
have an explanation
scientifically for how it moves that way
right when you get into that type of you
know understanding of some of this stuff
it's like look there's obviously things
that we don't understand in the world
right there was a time when people
didn't understand gravity now we have
better I'm sure there's other things
that we will discover over time but
there is this allure of scientifically
if we can't explain something but we can
see it happening like what the hell is
that
the attention so alright this more than
me out there absolutely is that's the
truest thing I've heard all day
I appreciate you taking the time to do
this this is awesome I really enjoyed
the conversation where can people go
find you or the work that you guys are
doing on a daily basis so my company's
name is the rethink group and we are the
rethink net website I wrote a book
called market mind games which is like
taking all this psychology and applying
it to the market decisions and making
places thank you market mind games there
were a lot of those going on right now
for sure awesome well thank you so much
for doing this we'll make sure we link
to all of that and we'll do this again
in the future
[Music]